he knows i'm not playing that great but
the points keep coming while i went my
way
okay i'm gonna go for the same banker
line
like why not
a3 this time take it
much for not quite sure who would put
his favors
to be fair so what i'm thinking now is
that after he takes i'm going to go r7
next
and probably be too happy probably be
quite happy that's what i meant to say
chicago knight f6 what is he even
thinking about
knight a6 question is if i can try
something immediately like c5
knight d5 it doesn't seem to work right
i i just got to develop
yeah i guess he could be okay here
d695 is gonna come at some point
okay castle castle
no need to rock the boat
just a playable position i hope
d6 is probably thinking about how to
deal with
knight d4 but i feel like he's got
several good options there like queen d7
maybe
this one i'm not sure i like for him
does he want take a knight f4
looks extremely artificial
but i guess that's what he wants
so i guess bishop f3 is going to go
f6
i can just go green e3 if i want
seems a tad soft
yeah this looks good
knight g4 what is he really achieved
d6 now
hasn't he just weakened
some very important squares now
let me see
namely e7 e7 looks very weak he does
have
a bunch of dark squares here but
not sure if they're gonna make him very
happy
okay just going d4
e5 is not possible because f6 is going
to be hanging after d6
so he goes for this
okay bring the knight into the game
yeah maybe it's not so clear
he does have strong some strong points
knight six can always be met by king g7
so that's that's not a big deal
okay let me try and attack
ooh
yeah this was really bad
94 i have to go what i wanted was knight
c2 but he's got knight f5
which is really bad news i don't know
i'm not sure where he went
for this though maybe 94 was just good
and i just locked into
a good position there
yeah it's definitely a lot worse now
just grab a phone i guess
okay four pawn looks
mighty juicy you know e5 at some point
exploiting that pin
yeah that's what he does but it's not
going to give him a lot of joy
[Music]
92 i guess
running queen a1 and also
protecting the rook
i got a bunch of options here like one
g5 queen h6 also
i guess i'm just gonna play it simple
okay we're gonna exchange the queens and
first of all my position is extremely
good and the second one
in time so no worries
there